[Musik]
was nun herr lindner bis letzte woche
war für sie klar dass armin laschet
bundeskanzler wird angesichts der
umfrage entwicklung der union stellt
sich die frage hat da ihr politisches
urteilsvermögen versagt oder glauben sie
ernsthaft und auch am heutigen tag noch
dass armin laschet es schaffen kann
die schwäche der union ist überraschend
die inhaltliche unschärfe von cdu und
csu bisweilen auch dennoch ist das
rennen offen ich halte es unverändert
für gut möglich dass armin laschet der
nächste kanzler der bundesrepublik
deutschland ist vor allen dingen auch
weil er solidere koalitionsoptionen hat
denn spd und grüne müssen sich ja auf
der linkspartei abstützen und das werden
wir in dieser sendung mal ein bisschen
durchdeklinieren wenn sie sagen dass es
überraschend was überrascht sie denn
daran eigentlich sie regieren ja mit
armin laschet zusammen sie kennen sich
gut was ist ihre erklärung dass seine
persönlichen werte auch die der union so
deutlich verloren
natürlich gilt meine erste sorge dass
werden sie verstehen nicht der union
sondern meiner partei der fdp aber ich
glaube dass es gründe gibt im
inhaltlichen kurs zum einen war lange
unklar und ist es im grunde bis heute
für was steht die union in der
steuerpolitik im programm ist etwas
geschrieben worden von entlastungen das
hat herr laschet relativiert man weiß es
nicht mehr genau
ich bin der meinung wir müssen
steuererhöhungen ausschließen und zum
zweiten auch hinsichtlich der
schuldenbremse wird zum beispiel auch
von markus söder laut gedacht da gibt es
eine annäherung inzwischen an die
positionen der grünen und das angesichts
des defizits im haushalt der schulden
und der inflationsrisiken in europa und
ich glaube dass dieser diese unschärfe
im kurs ihr übriges tut sie wollen ja
mit der union regieren mit der cdu
regieren deshalb könnte man natürlich
auch ein stück weit über wahlhilfe
sozusagen
nachdenken jetzt wirft ihnen frau
klöckner vor dass ihre äußerungen dass
armin laschet es noch schafft
die wähler in die irre führen würden
also ist das eine aufforderung zur wahl
hilfe
solcher äußerungen aus der cdu muss man
mit der situation
glaube ich erklären und auch
entschuldigen es gibt dort jetzt
versuche gegen die fdp wahlkampf zu
führen
das muss man das muss man hinnehmen
markus söder hat gestern abend sie haben
ja gerade schon zitiert im heute journal
gesagt armin laschet muss diese woche
noch die trendwende schaffen was
ähnliches haben sie vor einer woche
gesagt sie haben gesagt er muss er einen
neuen kurs sozusagen festlegen um
erfolgreich zu werden haben sie noch
eine idee der erst schaffen könnte also
ich fühle mich wirklich überfordert wenn
ich jetzt der union ratschläge geben
sollte das würde auch etwas gönnerhaft
wirken und im übrigen wäre es auch eine
überschätzung mir genug zu tun aber eins
kann man sicherlich feststellen herr
frei durch die schwäche der union
und durch das liebäugeln von spd und
grünen mit der linkspartei kommt der fdp
eine besondere bedeutung zu wenn man
eine politik der mitte in deutschland
will dann müssen die freien demokraten
stark werden dann müssen wir die
möglichkeit haben auf
regierungs formate also koalitionen und
auf inhalte einfluss zu nehmen es
konkret zu sagen unser ziel ist ja stark
zweistellig zu werden
aber es wäre sicherlich gut wenn die fdp
möglichst nah an die grünen herankommt
aufschließt zu den grünen weil wir dann
eine starke position nach der wahl haben
man wird man merkt eine bestimmte
bewegung herr lindner schon seit einigen
monaten in diesem wahlkampf nämlich die
union wird schlechter und die fdp
profitiert wahrscheinlich auch davon von
der schwäche der union dass sie davon
etwas haben das sie profitieren legt sie
das nicht im grunde in den augen ihrer
wellen wähler darauf fest dass sie es
eben doch nur mit der union machen wir
entscheiden ist nach inhalten wie
entscheidend koalitionsfragen nach
inhalten und wir wollen zum einen jahr
klimaschutz nicht mit verboten sondern
zu einer technologie frage machen wir
wollen dass nach einem jahrzehnt der
belastung wir eine trendwende bekommen
zu einem jahrzehnt der entlastung wir
haben zum dritten das ziel in bildung zu
investieren statt nur umverteilung zu
organisieren ich glaube die korona
pandemie hat ja gezeigt dass da viel zu
tun ist wir wollen solide finanzen also
schuldenbremse erhalten in europa keine
vergemeinschaftung der schulden und wir
wollen nach der pandemie endlich diese
politik der grundrechtseingriffe beenden
und wollen sozusagen dem werte der
freiheit neuer geltung verschaffen und
diese eine sekunde voraus wie das so
darstelle dann ergibt sich daraus eine
eigenständige position der fdp aber eine
größere inhaltliche nähe natürlich zur
union als zu spd und grünen ja sie
wollen es nach inhalten machen sie sagen
aber ja auch immer sie wollen das
korrektiv sein in einer
jamaika-koalition
aber sie könnten ja auch ein korrektiv
sein wenn es richtung rot grün rot gehen
sollte werden sie dazu bereit für dich
merz sagt jetzt heute die fdp soll die
ampel ausschließen aber können sie das
überhaupt wollen sie das
nur verhindern wer eine ein sehr
bescheidener anspruch neuer dinge nach
vorne entwickeln man in welcher
situation ist unser land bei
digitalisierung bei klimaschutz haben
wir keine zeit zu verlieren die
wirtschaftliche erholung frau schausten
läuft woanders besser als in deutschland
also nur zu sagen verhindern wäre für
mich zu bescheiden da muss mehr
passieren oder um es auf den punkt zu
bringen wer fdp wählt der muss jetzt
damit rechnen dass am ende die ampel
kommt und dass sie mit spd und grünen
regiert wer fdp wählt kann sich einer
tatsache sicher sein die fdp wird keine
linke politik in deutschland machen wir
werden keine linksverschiebung in
deutschland unterstützen und sie mit
erst mit den grünen regieren dann schon
ja aber schauen sie ich glaube dass die
fdp
glaubwürdigkeit capital hat wir haben
nämlich und deshalb ist die aufforderung
von friedrich merz ja nicht völlig frei
von ironie wir haben ja vor vier jahren
bei der damals beabsichtigten
verschiebung nach links durch jamaika
mit frau merkel und den grünen nein
gesagt und das ist interessant
seinerzeit vor vier jahren war die union
bereit gewissermaßen die
richtlinienkompetenz in wesentlichen
fragen der energiepolitik der
einwanderungspolitik
auch in teilen der wirtschaftspolitik an
die grünen abzugeben wir nicht und die
ironie der geschichte ist jetzt fordert
ausgerechnet die partei die nach links
ganz offen war die fdp auf irgendetwas
hören sie denn auch heraus wenn olaf
scholz jetzt sehr viel verständnis für
die fdp äußert dass er
2017 durchaus wahrgenommen hat aus
welchen gründen sie die verhandlungen
die sondierungen jamaika verlassen haben
hören sie da so ein bisschen raus dass
das ein bisschen erwachsen sind in
richtung fdp nehmen sie das wahr ist das
wirklich so unüberbrückbar so kann man
die äußerungen von herrn scholz
interpretieren er äußerte jetzt
verständnis dafür dass die fdp
seinerzeit auch eigene anliegen haben
wollte und nicht nur
mehrheitsbeschafferin sein wollte das
ist sicherlich als ein solches signal
verstehen nur wenn man sich die inhalte
an sieht frau schausten
ich habe großen respekt vor unseren
geschätzten mitbewerberinnen und
mitbewerber an spd und grüne sind
respektable parteien aber die haben ja
eigene inhalte wie wollen die steuern
erhöhen die schuldenbremse aufweichen
die grünen haben viele verbote im gepäck
also wo soll das innerhalb von sieben
tagen in vielfalt aber vielfach aber
wenn man mal ganz konkret guckt bei der
rückkehr zur schuldenbremse ist das
wirklich so ein knackpunkt wo sie mut
oder scholz so gar nicht so zusammen
kämen das jedenfalls vertritt er ja auch
kevin kühnert saskia esken und vor allen
dingen die grünen vertreten anderes und
es ist ja nicht eine koalition wo herr
scholz alleine der fdp angebote macht
und man darf ja auch nicht überfordern
schauen sich die sind ja eine partei wir
haben jetzt erfreuliche umfragen werden
vielleicht auch ein gutes ergebnis
erzielen aber wir können ja einer
regierung nicht den kurs diktieren also
muss man schauen in welchem umfeld kommt
man zusammen und wenn die unterschiede
so groß sind wie zwischen spd und grünen
weiß ich nicht wie herr scholz 1 für uns
akzeptables angebot seiner eigenen
partei aber es geht ja in der politik
nicht um die angebote die anderen machen
sondern es geht um den auftrag den
wählerinnen und wähler eingeben um dann
politik zu gestalten und sie haben jetzt
noch nicht gesagt dass sie die ampel
ausschließen sie haben inhaltliche
forderungen gestellt aber wir wollen
heute abend von ihnen wissen ob sie im
prinzip dafür offen sind wenn es keine
anderen optionen gibt kein option mit
der union wir entscheiden ja koalitionen
wirklich nach inhalten herr frey und in
meiner partei gibt es eine sehr
verbreitete überzeugung dass die fdp
2017 dass sie auch unterstrichen hat
dass wir nicht um jeden preis regieren
dass es uns nicht um karrieren geht und
wir uns nicht in bündnisse einbinden
lassen wenn ich auch etwas von unseren
wir legen uns am ende inhaltlich
rauszufinden müssen sie anfangen zu
reden wenn das wahlergebnis so ist wie
es ist dann werden sie so ein dia und
die frage ist werden sie in diesen
sondierungen drin sind also ein
ernsthafter prozess begonnen hat ob sie
dann noch mal so frei sind zu sagen wie
wir das zitat besser nicht regieren als
falsch regieren können sie sich dass ein
zweites mal leisten im gegenteil wir
haben seinerzeit ja für uns eine
glaubwürdigkeit unterstrichen und wie
würde es wirken wenn wir vier jahre
später das gegenteil von dem machen was
wir damals getan haben nur damit kein
falscher eindruck entsteht die fdp
wollte und will gerne gestalten und
verantwortung übernehmen wenn man gut
regieren kann wollen wir das land ja
nicht anderen überlassen
wir wollen dass deutschland aus der
mitte regiert wird weshalb unser
wahlziel immer schon war keine
schwarz-grüne koalition in hessen und
baden württemberg sieht man das führt
nach links und keine rot grün rote
mehrheit dafür werben wir als ein
eigenständiges politisches angebot und
uns kann man glauben schenken das für
uns der wert der freiheit wichtig ist
dass wir erwirtschaften wollen und nicht
mehr ans verteilen denken dass wir mehr
freude am erfinden als und sie legen
sich nicht fest das merken wir schon
ihre ihre wähler erwarten zu ich glaube
über 80 prozent schon dass die fdp mit
der union geht das ist eher die
erwartung halten sie es einfach auch
deshalb offen weil es nicht nur daran
geht darum geht ob sie vielleicht wollen
mit herrn scholz sondern dass die gefahr
für sie viel größer ist dass sie
verschmäht werden
nein diesen dieser gedanke leitet uns
deshalb nehmen wollen wir mal geht
christian den man nochmal in die
opposition der christian lindner möchte
gerne mit seiner partei in diesem land
gestalten weil wir wenig zeit zu
verlieren haben sowie die situation ist
aber wir haben auch die innere freiheit
zu sagen wir geben unseren wählerinnen
und wählern zu sagen die kann man in
unserem programm nach lehrers ich habe
es gerade auch kurzvorschau freiheit
stadtstaat erwirtschaften stadt
verteilen statt verbieten um schlagworte
zu wollen wir uns messen ist fällt auf
dass sie jetzt auch in dieser sendung
sozusagen nicht klar sagen dass sie wenn
es nicht anders geht sozusagen auch die
in dieser ampel koalition eintreten aber
haben wir reden viel jetzt mache ich mal
den punkt reden viel über inhalte wo sie
ganz klar sind sie wollen finanzminister
werden da reden sie gar nicht drum rum
und sie beanspruchen dieses geradezu für
sich was soll das fragt man sich der
posten steht gar nicht zur wahl sie sind
so eine art ersatz kanzler geworden
ich muss die ansatz findet mit 40
finanzminister kandidaten das war
feiertag frei aber der kanzler steht
auch nicht zur wahl stehen parteien zur
wahl parteien haben erklärt sie nennen
ihre spitzenkandidaten kanzlerkandidaten
aber gewählt wird immer nur eine partei
aber werden sie ihren anspruch was heißt
anspruch worauf gründen die grünen den
anspruch das kanzleramt zu besetzen also
sie sagen und was sie sind zäh im moment
das ganz kurz darauf hinweisen die fdp
hat darauf verzichtet obwohl wir bestand
heute drei prozentpunkte hinter den
grünen in manchen umfragen liegen nur
drei prozentpunkte haben wir keine
kanzlerkandidatur angemeldet weil wir
realisten aber frau waren sie ja auch
sehr stark kritisierte anhalten ich
glaube im persönlichen bereich nicht von
ihnen aber mal die erste frage anders
als ihr wissen finanzminister
schuldfrage steinbrück reiche waren auch
sie nie minister sie waren noch nie
ministerpräsidenten also worauf gründen
sie den anspruch sie sind kein
studierter ökonom eine autonome fragen
jetzt mich als als person und nicht die
fdp ich frage sie als person da sehen
wir uns ja wehren sie nach meiner
persönlichen qualifikation frage ich
führe nun seit zehn jahren partei
fraktions apparate und ich glaube dass
die politischen inhalte für die ich mit
der fdp stehe uns qualifizieren in
deutschland für solide finanzen und
wirtschaftliche vernunft zu sorgen da
müssten sich andere fragen stellen ob
sie eigentlich tatsächlich ausweislich
ihrer politischen ergebnislage bayern
war stolz sage ich mal wirecard und
comex dient ein haushalt der solche
hypotheken für die zukunft enthält weil
ohne nachhaltige finanzierung leistungen
ausgeweitet wenn wir müssen sich andere
eher eine frage zu dem komplex dann doch
noch abschließend denn die fdp hat ja
auch eine große tradition was aus der
politik angeht das interessiert sie
offenbar nicht will ich doch noch mal
fragen der studien schluss den schluss
dürfen sie nichts in denen darf ich
nicht sehen aber sie haben gesagt das
schlage ich auch haben alter fehler den
wir haben es nicht auf den guido
westerwelle damals möglicherweise
gemacht hat den sie wir haben liegen
sollen wir haben es nichts nichts
ausgeschlagen ich will es noch mal noch
einmal erläutern wenn die fdp in einer
regierung eintritt was wir wollen dann
wollen wir selbstverständlich auch
unseren anliegen geltung verschaffen es
gibt auch hier nicht um die karriere von
christian lindner machen sie sich um
mich bitte keine sorgen dass gar keine
sondern es
geht darum kann die fdp ihre
inhaltlichen anliegen unterbringen und
dafür muss man wenn man nicht das
kanzleramt hat in einem haus gestalt und
unser angebot ist weil wir glauben wir
verstehen etwas davon wie man die
staatsfinanzen stabilisiert wir
verstehen etwas davon wie wir
wirtschaftliche dynamik organisieren aus
denen jobs und start-ups und wachstum
entsteht ist unser angebot in einer
koalition okay so der gängige diese
schwierige aufgabe der finanzen da wären
wir bereit verantwortung zu übernehmen
also ein reagiert job ist es jedenfalls
nicht in den nächsten jahren sie sagen
die eignung ist da und sie sagen auch es
geht nicht um ihre karriere dann die
frage wenn sie als parteivorsitzender
die fdp dieses jahr nicht in die
regierung führen worauf sie acht jahre
hingearbeitet haben ziehen sie sich dann
von der parteispitze zurück
selbstverständlich nicht wir haben
gerade einen mitgliederrekord bei der
fdp wir haben so viele mitglieder wie
seit der deutschen einheit nicht mehr
seit der vereinigung mit der damaligen
ltd ldpd
der ddr haben mitgliederrekord ich werde
doch auf gar keinen fall die menschen
die vertrauen in die fdp investieren die
werde ich doch nicht dadurch enttäuschen
ok hätten zu unserer sendung gehört die
satz ergänzung sie kennen das vom zu
sehen wir geben einen halbsatz vor und
sie ergänzen in bitburg ist kurz in der
zeitschrift bunte das will ich vorweg
nehmen haben sie kürzlich ihren
kinderwunsch thematisiert und gesagt
nach bald zwei drei oder vier mädchen
oder jungs das ist das ziel so zusagen
von christiana die tat jedenfalls der
erste halbsatz da lautet deshalb dass
ich als finanzminister keine elternzeit
nehmen würde ist
in diesen ämtern wohl so vorgesehen dass
väter und mütter sich grundsätzlich die
altenarbeit teilen sollten ist ein gutes
ziel das ich unterstützung auch für
wünschenswert halte weil man ja etwas
auf an seinen kindern haben möchte dass
ich mehr als künftiger familienvater
einen lastenfahrrad anschaffen würde
ist eher weniger wahrscheinlich dass
olaf scholz die geimpften jetzt
versuchskaninchen genannt hat
ist glaube ich missverstanden worden und
war von ihm so nicht gemeint wie manche
es aufgefasst an angela merkel werde ich
nach ihrem abschied am meisten vermissen
ihre unbedingte einsatzbereitschaft für
unser land dass die man anerkennen muss
selbst wenn man mit ergebnissen nicht
immer einverstanden war in einer
koalition ein tempolimit von 130 zu
beschließen
entscheiden die wählerinnen und wähler
am 26.9 es ist keine frage des
klimaschutzes sondern eine frage ob man
menschen vernünftige entscheidungen
zutraut oder nicht dass die nächste
bundesregierung die letzte ist die noch
aktiv den klimawandel aufhalten kann ist
pessimistisch gedacht aber die
dringlichkeit der frage sollte uns allen
vor augen stehen wir müssen da ein
globales vorbild sein als technologie
nation aber zum schluss herr lindner
kommen wir zur corona pandemie seit
anderthalb jahren profilieren sie sich
als liberale gegenstimme zur regierung
haben sie eine erklärung warum der
ansatz auf die eigenverantwortung der
menschen zu setzen gerade zu scheitern
droht dann ende dieses sommers mit
steigenden instanzen und stagnierenden
im pferd
ich teile ihre einschätzung nicht weil
allein an der inzidenz kann man ja die
gefährlichkeit der pandemie nicht messen
sondern sind anderen auf kroos
realisierung stein und andere ihr aber
wir sind noch von einer überlastung des
gesundheitssystems jahr weit entfernt
aber in einem punkt gebe ich ihnen recht
was mich bei der regierung bislang nicht
überzeugt ist dass gesprochen wird über
niedrigschwellige mobile
angebote aber bei den sport- und
kulturveranstaltungen in den
einkaufszentren auf dem uni-campus sieht
man noch nicht überall diese mobilen
angebote niedrigschwellig und spontan
ich glaube dass wir da aufmerksamkeit
dass wir dort zeit investieren es geht
es bei den deutschen am ende nicht ohne
eine impfpflicht wenn man mal den
vergleich nach italien macht deutlich
stärkere impfquote als hier die
impfquote muss steigen dafür werbe ich
auch aber eine impfpflicht wäre nicht
verhältnismäßig denn die einmalige
impfung gegen korona immunisiert nicht
für das ganze leben da wo wir eine
impfpflicht haben wir etwa bei den
masern sagt die
weltgesundheitsorganisation das ziel ist
die ausrottung dieses ziel ist leider
beim koma virus nicht realistisch und
allein aus diesen beiden gründen ist
eine impfpflicht nicht verhältnismäßig
wenn man das mit den masern wo wir sie
haben vergleich heute in drei wochen
kennen wir den wahlausgang kennen
vielleicht noch nicht den der enns
kanzler oder die die ins kanzleramt
einzieht gehen sie eine wette an sehen
sie ich habe ihnen gesagt ich
sehe armin laschet wegen der
koalitionsoptionen in einer soliden
ausgangslage aber vorne ist wenn er
nicht vorne ist dann geht es um das
entscheidende nämlich eine mehrheit im
deutschen bundestag
ich erinnere daran dass
1976 helmut kohl die absolute mehrheit
nahezu erreicht hat und dennoch wurde
helmut schmidt wieder bundeskanzler
zweiter ist ins kanzleramt einzieht
selbstverständlich weil es entscheidet
die mehrheit im deutschen bundestag also
die koalitionsbildung deshalb ist ja so
wichtig wie stark die fdp ab schneidet
damit wir auch einfluss nehmen können
auf regierungs formate und die inhalte
die dann entschieden werden dann
bestimmen christian lindner das war was
nun und jetzt direkt und schnell weiter
denn wieso wartet in diesem programm
vielen dank danke
[Musik]